FEMALE SPEAKER: Hi, everyone.
Thank you for coming.
My name is [INAUDIBLE] and
I'm on diversity [INAUDIBLE]
sourcing team in Sunnyvale.
I'm very excited to welcome
Adisa Banjoko to Google,
and he's going to talk about
his latest book, "Bobby,
Bruce, and the Bronx-- the
Secrets of Hip-Hop Chess."
So I met Adisa for the first
time at Rock the School Bells.
It's a conference for
students and educators.
The purpose was
to give workshops
to enhance their ability
to critically think
about current issues
through hip-hop.
So Adisa gave one of
the presentations,
and after that I learned
more about connections
between hip-hop and chess.
So I'm really excited to know
more about it and his book.
So I'd like to talk a
little bit more about Adisa.
So he covered Eazy-E and NWA.
He was one of the first
writers to cover them.
And he went on to
write early rap
publications such as
Source, Vibe, and Rap Pages.
And he also-- he was also
one of the first writers
to cover the articles connecting
hip-hop to Eastern philosophy
and martial arts.
And he also-- he's work of
Hip-Hop Chess Federation.
So it's a nonprofit
organization,
and it's to help young
people overcome difficulties
through hip-hop,
martial arts, and chess,
and it was covered by Rolling
Stone, Forbes, and "Good
Morning America," and so on.
So without further ado, please
help me welcome Adisa Banjoko.
[APPLAUSE]
ADISA BANJOKO: Is this thing on?
Thank you guys for coming out.
It's really awesome to
be here, so thank you.
So if you notice,
the title of the book
was a little different
a couple weeks ago when
I started this thing.
"Bobby, Bruce, & Bam," right.
So we're talking about
Bobby Fischer, Bruce Lee,
and Afrika Bambaataa.
So you'll see him there
and you see him there.
Unfortunately, despite
being a pioneer of hip-hop,
he's been caught up
in an insane scandal.
So we switched it to "Bobby,
Bruce, and the Bronx,"
which is where he's
originally from.
So this whole thing is changing.
You can go to
BobbyBruceAndBam.com
and still buy this book as it
looks, but in about 72 hours,
it's "Bobby, Bruce,
and the Bronx."
MALE SPEAKER: It's
changed already.
I just went to it.
The domain's off.
ADISA BANJOKO: Is it off?
Yeah, see, I got good people.
They're already like--
[LAUGHTER]
--they're good people,
like, we're switching it.
So I just got the
new cover last night.
So in any case,
my name is Adisa.
My nickname is the Bishop.
You know, my nonprofit.
Hip-Hope Chess Federation,
fuses music, chess,
and martial arts to
promote unity, strategy,
and nonviolence.
Essentially, when
I was young, I was
obsessed with kung fu films.
I was obsessed with
the television show
"Kung Fu," Bruce Lee films.
And when I got
older, I started--
my first interview,
my first job writing,
was to interview Eazy-E for
my high school newspaper.
And at the time, I was
kind of hustling him.
He didn't know.
Like, they had just dropped the
record and I called over there
and I was like, hello,
is Eazy-E there?
And they were like, no.
I left him a message.
I was like, I'm a big-time
writer from the Bay Area.
I'd love to connect with him.
Can you have him call me?
And then when I came
back, my mom was like,
oh, this boy named Eric
left a message for you
from Los Angeles.
And I was like, really?
So then I called.
He was like, hello?
And it was his house.
It was his home number.
I was like, uh,
yeah, I really like
the record "Boyz in the Hood."
I think it would be good
if I did a story on you.
So he was like, OK.
So over the course of some
weeks, I keep talking with him,
and I interviewed him.
My mom was a secretary,
so she had all the stuff
that you could hook up
the phones at the time
to record interviews.
So I recorded this
interview with him.
And we just became like,
it was this odd friendship
between this gangster rapper
and this suburban black kid.
And I remember one day,
he's like, so hey, man,
is this going on
"The Chronicle"?
My manager meant to
ask me to ask you,
is it in "The Examiner"?
Like, who do you write for?
And I was like, I
gotta be honest, man.
I'm just a 17-year-old kid, man.
I just really like your music.
And the song really
wasn't a hit.
I mean, "Boyz in the Hood" was
only like maybe a month old.
So he was like, I don't care.
This is awesome.
Let's do the story.
So I did the story,
and we stayed cool
until he passed away.
But that's how I got
my start writing.
And so this was before
hip-hop magazines existed.
You know, there was no "Source."
There was no AllHipHop.com,
no World Star.
None of that stuff existed.
So the more that I started
listening to hip-hop,
around that same time, I'm
listening to Public Enemy,
and I'm hearing them say things
like, "no matter what the name,
we're all the same, pieces
in one big chess game."
And so lyrics like that, because
I liked chess-- and I do,
I love chess.
I'm just not that good at it.
So do not think I'm like going
to wow you on the boards at all
ever.
But the reason I liked
it is because I started
learning things about life,
about patience and things
like that.
And the more I listened
to hop-hop over the years,
I made this bank in my
head of what was what.
And so I started realizing
that these connections were
really deep.
Later on, I created the
Hop-Hop Chess Federation, 2006,
and the way that happened is
I went for an author visit
for one of my other
previous books,
which was called
"Lyrical Swords."
It was my first book.
And so I went into
the juvenile hall.
I was bombing,
because they wanted
me to talk about journalism as
a career, and none of the kids
cared about journalism.
They're like, you
ever met Snoop Dogg?
I talked to him
on the phone once.
You ever met so and so?
They didn't care
about writing at all.
So I was like, all right,
so, do any of you guys
know how to play chess?
Because I just started
teaching my son
chess, and I just happened
to have the pieces
in a bag in my thing.
So I'm like, I'm going to waste
time teaching these kids chess,
because I'm sure they
don't know how to play.
I said, who here knows
how to play chess?
And like 85% of the room.
I was like, OK, so,
who's the best in here?
I only want you keep your
hand up if you're the best.
Only the best.
And then only a few
hands went down.
I was like, here's
what we're gonna do.
We're going to have a
tournament right now.
Whoever wins will get a book.
They were like, all right.
So everybody circles up.
So the first game, these
two black kids are playing,
and there was this white
kid who was in the hall,
and he was in the inner circle.
So the guy was getting
ready to move his knight,
and he was like, don't
move your knight.
And dude was like,
shut up white boy.
Nobody asked you nothing.
So he moves his knight, loses
his queen, loses the game.
And then everybody's like, oh,
the white boy knows what's up.
We gotta pay
attention when he's--
So then when I first
asked who the best was,
there was this kid in the back.
He was obese.
He was like 300 pounds.
He was in the back.
And I was like, you the best?
And they're like,
shut up, fat boy,
this isn't a sandwich
eating contest.
And everybody's like,
laughing at him.
He's like no, no,
I'm really the best.
So I said, all right, come here.
Come here.
I was like, all right, so
my boy says he's the best.
We're going to see what happens.
So he plays, and he does.
He beats everybody.
He gets a book.
And what I saw was that racial
barriers, and pecking order--
you know what I mean, in the
traditional pecking order,
the obese kid wasn't
really respected.
But now he was respected.
And I was like, man, how crazy
is it that all of these kids
actually know the
game, can play it well,
but they've made mistakes in
their life that landed them
here?
That doesn't even make sense.
So as I was leaving,
all the rap lyrics
I ever heard about chess in
that bank that I'd been making,
they all just hit me.
And I was like, all right,
all right, this is the thing.
If I take the rap lyrics
to lure the kids in,
I can start teaching
them more about chess.
But then that even
wasn't enough, right.
I mean, chess is awesome.
It's a great game.
It's one of the few global
games that people play.
If we got on a plane
and went anywhere,
I guarantee you almost
in any city we landed in,
we would find some people
playing outside playing chess.
And then while we were
playing, somebody's
going to drive by banging
out Jay-Z, banging out
Wu-Tang, or, know what I'm
saying, 50, whoever, Drake.
And all of those guys have
mentioned chess in their music.
So I was like, well,
if chess isn't enough,
it has to be about life
and stuff like that.
So at that point, I started
researching chess more.
And it turned into
what we have now,
the Hop-Hop Chess Federation.
And so we don't
just teach chess.
We have a bunch of
life strategies.
Some of the life strategies
are in the book--
the first 12 filters,
different ways
that you can look at long-
and short-term goal planning,
look at recovering
from loss, look
at just being more patient
about the idea of what you can
do with any given situation.
And emotional control.
I was working-- to
create the book,
I started doing research
by working at a school.
But I didn't have a
teaching credential,
so I got in as a security guard.
And it was crazy.
I saw crazy stuff going.
I learned a lot about American
education and its failures
and some of its strengths.
But I also mainly learned
a lot about drug abuse,
alcohol abuse, gangs.
I learned a lot about violence.
I learned a lot about
how to communicate
with kids who are really
active gang members,
you know what I mean,
or live in those areas.
And one of the main
things I learned about
is how many of our children
in America, especially
in the urban sectors, they
have-- basically they're
walking around with
post-traumatic stress disorder.
And it's undiagnosed
and it's untreated.
And then we're saying, but how
come Johnny doesn't have all
A's?
Well, because Johnny's
thinking about
he might actually catch a bullet
either on the way to school
or on the way back.
Or some of these girls, you
know, that carry knives,
not because they're bad people
but because they get harassed
and they don't-- you
know what I mean?
They don't have any protection.
And so that kind
of stuff, it really
elevates their stress levels
and their sense of focus.
And so here we have
this Venn diagram here,
where you can see
these overlapping
themes between music,
chess, and martial arts.
Nonviolence is such a really
big part of what we do,
and we do it through
teaching martial arts.
A lot of times
when I say we teach
jiu-jitsu, people are like,
wait, what's going on?
Because rap already has this
frame of being super violent.
So then it's like,
hey, what's going
on with the jiu-jitsu, man?
And I'm like, well,
really, if you
look at-- if you think
about who are some
of the most nonviolent and
peaceful people on the planet,
you say, well, you
know, Buddhist monks
or Shaolin monks.
I'm like, exactly.
And they train their whole
life in blades, in punching,
in kicking, in throwing
stars and all these weapons.
And it's because they have
confronted all of these fears
and all of these concerns
about violence and everything
else that they're
completely at peace.
And so people don't
understand that.
A lot of the
violence that happens
is because these kids
are stressed out.
They don't have any
physical outlets.
They have no way and no filter
of how to assess and understand
what's really happening.
And that's why they lash out.
And so that's why Brazilian
jiu-jitsu is what we teach.
And so this is at
one of the schools
here in the Bay, down
in East Side San Jose.
And it was really crazy,
because this school,
when I started teaching there,
just a few kids played chess.
And then by the
time-- I was only
there for like a month or two,
I would open my classroom up
at lunch to have
games, and we would
have near riots over games.
When you see this girl here, she
had just begun playing chess,
and then she ended up being
like one of the strongest
players in the school.
And I remember at
one point they had--
she was basically at
the end of a tournament,
and there was this boy.
And then the guys had
kind of come in first,
and they were all kind
of milling around,
and this armada of girls came.
And like, 'cause Amber,
she walked in first,
and her head was kind of down.
She was kind of in everything.
And there were like 12
girls who came to the door.
And I'm like, what's up?
And they're like,
we're here for Amber.
I was like, OK, welcome.
So they came in, and
they had this huge game,
and then she won it after
being chased around the board
with very little material,
but she figured out
how to outsmart
the dude and win.
And like the school was nuts.
And I used to be like, hey, you
guys got to-- it's chess, man.
They were just too wild.
So again, unity,
strategy, and nonviolence.
When you're teaching
chess, you're
essentially teaching strategy.
And when you're
teaching, strategy
comes from a Latin
root word, strategos,
which means leader of the army.
That's what chess is about.
If we want to get
kids out of gangs,
if we want to get them out of
doing all kinds of wild group
activities, we need to
help them to be comfortable
believing in the power
of their own decision
and trusting their own decision.
And so leadership is such a
big part of what we do here.
That's one of my
students right there.
He's actually blind,
and I currently
teach him chess and jiu-jitsu.
And we have a chess and
entrepreneurship class.
Entrepreneurship
is such a big deal
because I think as the American
economy and the world economy
continues to become
more digital,
that kids can actualize their
ideas for business purposes
faster than ever.
And even just their
access to information
has never been greater.
So I was meeting with-- I
was talking with some kids
just last week, and I was
like, my daughter taught
herself Python between the
ages of like 12 and 14.
She could make like
80 grand a year
just based on what
she knows, dude.
I know you could do
something like that.
You don't have to
go learn Python,
but you could do something.
And so this youngster
here, because he's blind,
he wanted to create a phone app
that helps people order food,
because his retinas
don't function.
So even though he can
kind of walk around--
sometimes he uses a cane,
sometimes he doesn't-- he
can't read menus.
So he created this
idea for an app
called Eye Menu,
like E-Y-E, Eye Menu,
and it's going to help
people read menus.
And it has a Siri
component, so people,
even if you can't see what's
on the phone, you can hear it.
And so I helped him put
everything together.
And then he went
and did this pitch,
and he was awarded 100,000.
And so we're working
on the app right now.
This is me and Tupac.
That's Pac on the
right, obviously.
And he was a chess player.
He was a friend of mine.
We met that moment.
We had only known each other
for one minute at that point.
But we met through the guy on
the left with the polka dots.
And you know, me and
Pac were always cool.
You know, he was a chess player.
And so if you see Mr. Makaveli
moving pieces like telekinesis,
if it's a chess game, let's
play with real pieces.
Now that may or may not
make a lot of sense to you,
but really what that's about is
something that really brought
me to love chess and this idea
of fusing it with hip-hop,
and that is that a lot of really
good chess players are in jail.
They're in prison.
And if you go look
up, I think it
was-- was it the
Princeton chess team,
or I think it was
the Princeton chess
team went to go play at Rikers
and got housed-- housed, OK.
But in most prisons,
a lot of wardens
do not like the
inmates to play chess.
And they often take the
boards and pieces away
from the inmates.
And it seems to be based
around this really stupid idea
that the algebraic notation,
like when you're playing chess,
how you move to
e-4, e-5, they have
this idea that the inmates
will use the algebraic notation
to do something sinister.
And then the CO-- I
don't know what it means.
Oh, there's a riot.
But that's not going to happen.
And that's such an insane fear.
But it's real.
So a lot of times
they take it away.
I know inmates who have told
me that they've played chess
through the wall
with other inmates,
speaking in algebraic notation.
Do you realize the cognitive
function in play to do that?
That's insane, right?
And so one of the
things-- so when
he says it's a chess game, let's
play with real pieces, look,
he didn't say Tupac
was playing, he
said Makaveli's moving pieces.
Who's Makaveli?
Obviously the Italian
philosopher, writer,
whatever, who made
"The Prince," which
changed Tupac's
life, which made him
call himself Makaveli, right?
So it came to Pac during this
time when he was on lockdown.
And so he's talking about, I
can play with real pieces now,
you know what I'm saying?
Like, let's play
with real pieces.
I'm no longer in solitary.
That's the kind of psychology.
And the reason I mention
that is because so
many American children
are not getting groomed,
and not having their
cognitive functions
enhanced the way
that they could be.
And so I want more
technology companies
and I want more
innovators to start
looking in the hood for
these kinds of people.
Any kid who could
play blindfolded
speaking in algebraic
notation, they
could either be working here
or create the next Google.
There's a lot of wisdom
in our local community
that we're not cultivating.
And it's not their
fault that they're
from East Side San Jose.
It's not their fault
that they're from Oakland
or whatever.
It's not their fault
they're from East L.A.
But I know we can do more.
And so again, chess
and entrepreneurship.
When I talk to the kids,
Jay-Z, Will Smith, Drake,
J Cole, 50 Cent, RZA and
GZA, I remind the kids
that a lot of the top-tier
dudes are chess players.
But the reason why kids
in hip-hop play chess
is not to win trophies.
So like right now, you
know, Magnus Carlsen
is the world champion.
If you say, hey, what do
you think of Magnus Carlsen,
the average kid is going
to shrug their shoulders.
They don't know him.
They don't care.
They don't care because
they don't play chess
for the same reason.
They're playing it to get sharp.
I don't know if you've ever
seen the movie "Fresh."
it's a movie from the '80s about
this kid whose older sister is
being pimped out by
this heroin dealer,
but his father, who's
played by Samuel Jackson,
is a street hustler
who plays chess.
And so the more that the kid
plays chess with his father,
he figures out how he
can get his sister away
from the drug dealer.
And so it's a great film.
And then the movie like
"Searching for Bobby Fischer,"
you know, it's about Josh
Waitzkin, and so, you know,
Josh's entry into chess
is playing in the streets.
And then he gets a
classical teacher,
and there's kind of like
this philosophical breakdown,
and he ends up going back
to the street hustler
to help him get
his game back up.
And ironically,
in his real life,
he ends up quitting
chess and then going on
to get a black belt in
Brazilian jiu-jitsu,
and he's a really
good dude at that.
So I tell the kids, you know,
Jay-Z, Will Smith, these guys
are not successes by accident,
you know what I mean?
They think about what they do.
They plan what they do.
And you need these
tools to be successful,
and that any success that
you get that you haven't
planned for, you lose it.
You see people all the
time who win the lottery.
In three years they're broke
and back in the trailer
home or whatever, because they
don't know what they're doing.
They didn't plan
to have that money.
And so you should make
plans to have money.
You should make plans
to enhance your wisdom
and figure out where you're
going to be down the line
and how to quantify
it and qualify it.
And so that's what's in my book.
In the back they
have these 12 filters
about long- and short-term
goal planning and other things.
So this is one of the
highest moments of my life.
The World Chess Hall of Fame
called us, asked us to come out
and do basically an exhibit.
You know, it's like a museum.
And so when we
did this thing, it
was called Living like
Kings, our first day we
had more visitors than came to
the World Chess Hall of Fame
to see Bobby Fischer's exhibit.
Like, there were lines
around the block.
People couldn't get in.
They were mad.
And all of this stuff happened
during Mike Brown and Ferguson.
So like, the central west
end is where we were.
Ferguson was like 15 miles down
the road, and it was on fire
and there was helicopters and
there was all this madness.
But RZA and I went there.
We spoke to about 500
kids at this one event
about nonviolence.
And the police had
killed a kid the night
before, after Mike Brown.
His name was VonDerrit Myers.
And so me and RZA
are like, we're
about to do this
nonviolent talk now?
You know what I'm saying?
It's never been harder to sell.
But it worked.
The kids understood what
we were talking about.
And we left there and we
went to a juvenile hall,
where we played
chess with the kids
and talked to them
about chess and life.
And then we ended
up-- that's where
we started our first
program, actually,
was in the juvenile hall there.
And the reason I say that is
because I know this works,
in terms of teaching
nonviolence,
because of all the
rioting and the looting,
there was a completely
skewed experience of what
was happening in St. Louis.
But we were actively
and directly working
with kids in the hood, helping
them understand nonviolence,
and they were getting it.
And so that exhibit
lasted about a year.
And it was the second
biggest and most diverse
attended exhibit that they had.
And so I was really
proud of that.
I was really proud of that.
And so the main way
that we teach chess
is through teaching the
cultural connectivity.
Like, I went and did a talk at
Harvard School of Education.
This guy was like-- this
Latino kid came up to me.
He was like, I really like
your talk, but you know,
chess is just really an
old white man's game.
I don't understand why you're
using this old white man's game
to try to teach
kids in the hood.
That doesn't make any sense.
And I said, well, I
guess it all starts
with your
misunderstanding of chess.
The idea that you think
it's an old white man's game
is exactly why I teach.
And he was like,
what do you mean?
So I said, well, chess
comes from India.
And then the Arabs learned
it from the Indians,
and as they raided and traded
through the Horn of Africa
and came over to West Africa.
The Africans got it.
And then in 700 AD, they looked
across the Iberian Peninsula,
and this German guy had
a problem with someone
who had attacked his
daughter in Spain,
and he was like, I think they
got a lot of money in there,
man.
You guys should see what's up.
So the Moors were
like, let's go.
And they crossed the
Iberian Peninsula.
And they came in and
they brought algebra
and they brought the Greek
classics, which they had
been translating, from Baghdad.
And they brought chess boards.
And that's how the Jews and the
Christians started playing it.
So it goes from Spain
into France and Sicily,
and then eventually
it goes into England.
And you know, Benjamin
Franklin is the second American
by name known to play.
And he wrote this essay called
"On the Morals of Chess,"
and it breaks down how
chess helps your character.
And that small
essay alone totally
changed my life, like when I
started trying to figure out
that I'm going to do this.
And so I said, you know, the
first complete books on chess
were written by the Muslims.
But then the Jews innovated
and the Christians innovated,
and so everybody kind
of owns this game.
There's not a game that so many
different cultures and races
and face completely
are connected to.
And so this is why.
And he was like,
that's the story of it?
I was like, yeah,
that's the Cliff Notes.
I mean, it's much deeper.
But there's a book called
"The Immortal Game"
by David Shank you could read.
And an amazing woman
over at Stanford
wrote a book called "Birth
of the Chess Queen,"
about how the chess queen
wasn't an original piece.
It was the king and his vizier.
And then over time, as
the more women in Europe
started taking on
leadership positions
if the kings would die, the
queen gets on the board.
And she didn't start that
strong, but little by little,
over a couple centuries, she
becomes the strongest piece
on the board.
Telling that story
to young girls
totally changes their posture.
I see them sit up more.
And we say, look,
you know, it's not
enough to just
say you're a king,
or it's not enough to
say you're a queen.
Kings and queens move
in very specific ways.
So when you're
out on the street,
you can't just act any way.
You have to know that
queens don't move like that.
You have to move like a queen.
And then you will see
differences in your grades,
and you know what I mean, who
you are around and all that.
And so it's been a great ride.
So BobbyBruceAndTheBronx.com
is coming.
I just got a few more swaps.
And there's Emmanuel right
after he got his award,
and we're working on
Eye Menu right now.
We have a summer
camp we're doing.
And he learns jiu-jitsu, too.
He's going to have his
first jiu-jitsu tournament
in about four weeks in Alameda.
And we're starting
to slowly grow.
The other thing I want
to add before I finish
is just that one of the other
things that I've learned
is I started intending
this to take it
to black and Latino
kids in the hood.
That was my original
plan, because I
felt like a lot of the
American school systems
were ignoring them,
and there weren't
enough African-American
philanthropists
or whatever to help them.
So that's why I created this.
At risk-- so if I say
at risk, you know,
you're thinking, you
know, Latino guy who
might be a gang member,
or a black dude who
might be a crack dealer or
weed dealer or whatever.
That was my intention.
After I created it and the more
that I started engaging kids,
I realized that there was the
separate group of at-risk kids,
and they actually tend
to be white and Asian.
And they're actually just--
I was kind of loud and crazy,
but I was a nerd
when I was a kid.
But there are a lot of
kids who are just kind
of quiet and
reserved, and parents
will start bringing
me their kids,
and they'd be like,
hey, this is my son.
When he comes home, he
just sits in his room.
He doesn't go out.
He doesn't talk.
He doesn't do anything.
And I'm worried about him.
He hasn't done anything,
you know what I mean,
but he doesn't talk.
He sits in his room all day.
So I sat down with him,
talk to him about chess,
get him to play a little bit.
I know he's not
necessarily thrilled
about the idea of doing
jiu-jitsu because he's small
and he's not really engaging,
but I get him on the mat.
And now these kids are totally
different human beings.
And what I'm finding is
that this second group
of at-risk kids, they're a
lot bigger than we thought.
At the school that I was at
originally in San Francisco,
it was so wild with fights, with
blacks and Latinos and kids who
were cutting
themselves and kids who
were drinking and just wild,
that a lot of the Asian kids
aren't even considered,
right, because it's
like, as long as they're not
trying to shoot up the school
or start a fight,
we're happy with them.
But we don't know what's
happening in their head.
Like, that kid might
want to jump off
the third floor right now.
We have no idea.
So I would always refer to the
Asian kids as the invisibles,
because just because
they were quiet,
just because they were getting
A's, didn't mean they were OK.
And the school was
OK with, as long
as they weren't
actively fighting,
we didn't worry about them.
And so I think that there is
this second group of at-risk,
socially withdrawn kids, boys
and girls, that I'm noticing
in schools and in
America, and I think
that we should be working
on helping them as well.
You know, we need
to start working
on helping them as well.
And I think that chess is
just such a great tool.
It raises cognitive function.
Kids who study chess
have-- their math grades
are 15% higher.
Reading comprehension goes up.
There's so many
studies-- not even
recent studies, studies
that go all the way back
to the '70s that
talk about this.
And chess is so cheap.
There's no reason
we shouldn't have it
in every school every day across
America, especially when, I
mean, you've seen
the test scores.
Our kids need help.
And this is absolutely
a great tool.
So thank you for coming.
If you have any questions,
definitely feel free to ask.
On Instagram, I'm
@RealHipHopChess,
and you can see some of
the kids that I work with
and some of the
stuff we do there.
And then HipHopChess.com is
the regular site for the orb,
for the nonprofit, and
"Bobby, Bruce, and the Bronx."
Look for it.
Got some shirts over there.
You guys rock.
Any questions?
AUDIENCE: You mentioned
at-risk students.
I wanted to know,
what do you believe
are the characteristics
of your program
that they respond to that
maybe other programs,
other activities kids could
get involved with doesn't have?
Is it about personal attention?
Is it the subject matter
is interesting to them?
ADISA BANJOKO: You
know what it is?
I mean, most of the kids--
that's a great question,
and I think the first part
is just-- there's two things.
One, I don't think-- even a lot
of nonprofits that mean well,
I think that they
don't connect with kids
because they're afraid of
who they're trying to help.
So, we've got this great
after-school program,
but don't beat me up.
And so you can't teach
kids you're afraid of.
And the other part is,
you can't judge them.
So I didn't come in saying,
hey, so what's up, dude?
You look like you're a
Norteno, what's going on?
You want to sit?
I don't do that.
I just play chess.
And then little by
little, they see
that the judgment isn't there.
And then they'll be
like, man, you know,
I just stopped smoking weed.
Oh, for real?
OK.
You know what I mean?
And you know, that's it.
That may be the only thing
you get for like two weeks is
that they stopped smoking weed.
And then you'd just
be like, you smoking?
No?
OK, cool.
All right, that's good.
Don't smoke.
And little stuff like that.
And so I think it's just
the human engagement.
What I'm finding
is a lot of kids,
whether they're withdrawn,
like some of my newer students,
or whether they're gang impacted
or very active in the streets,
the lack of judgment and
the consistent engagement
is what makes it happen.
That's what makes it turn.
And then when you're
playing with them
and you're talking
about, well, why did you
move the knight there?
What did you think
was going to happen?
Then you're helping them.
Because chess is helping
them reassess their flaws,
and that's a hard
thing for anyone to do.
And they're using chess
as a filter to self-assess
and reassess.
And then when you help
them without judging them,
they want to learn more.
That's what I think.
Anyone else?
All right, well,
thank you very much.
I really do appreciate your
time, and this was awesome.
Thank you very much.
[APPLAUSE]
Thanks a lot.